it's great to welcome to the program
today Denise Hearn who is co-author of
the book the myth of capitalism
monopolies and the death of competition
which was named a best book of 2018 by
the Financial Times and is endorsed by
not one but two Nobel Prize winners
Denise really great to talk to you today
yeah thank you David for having me on so
this is a really interesting topic for a
few reasons one is that there's a very
sort of public conversation happening
about socialism and social democracy our
so-called democratic socialists actually
socialists or are they really Social
Democrats and how does that compare and
contrast with the system of capitalism
but a conversation that that's not
happening enough is do we even really
have the free market capitalist paradise
that many believe is the contrast to a
social democracy or democratic socialism
I believe that the answer is no and I
and I hope to get into some of the ways
in which that's the case but can you
kind of open up by talking about when we
talk about the United States as a
capitalist economy in what ways is it
but also in what ways is it really not
it's a great question because I think
when when we have these debates about
socialism versus capitalism people
haven't really defined terms and they
actually don't there's not agreement in
terms of what they actually mean and so
what they're arguing in favor for or
against we titled our book the myth of
capitalism because when we think about
the United States we think of it as the
bastion of free market capitalism
globally and as we did our research we
started to realize that actually the the
current a situation in the American
economy looks anything like free markets
it is controlled and dominated within
industries by you know handful of large
corporations across all industries
essentially so we're now in a position
where we have you know two companies
that control 75% of the beer that
Americans drink and for airlines that
dominate all air traffic and and you
know the list of industries with
dominant
endless and so what we discovered is
that you know it's not so much that
capitalism itself has a fundamental flaw
it's just that the current iteration of
what we're experiencing in the economy
is certainly not capitalism if you think
that capitalism as all dictionary
definitions to have must include
competition and so we've really moved
away from competitive marketplaces and
you know we think that that's incredibly
problematic for a number of reasons that
we discuss in the book yes so you've
pointed out the in some of the
industries in which we don't really have
the competition that so-called free
market capitalism claims to have or
claims that we should have we also have
any number of industries that are
heavily subsidized by the government and
when you hear the criticism that we
heard under the Obama administration
often from the right that the government
shouldn't pick winners and losers when
we heavily subsidize agribusiness when
we heavily subsidize the airline
industry when we talk about revitalizing
coal what we're talking about is
interrupting a free market that might
have coal die and saying we are going to
artificially prop that industry up so
there's the competition side and then
there's also and I'm curious whether how
you see this as related there's the
subsidy side where you see the
government interfering but in very
particular ways that are sort of within
the Overton Window of acceptability for
lack of a better term well and this is
where it's very interesting because you
recognize that the old the other old
debate about you know free markets
versus government interference is a
complete red herring because the
government has been bought by corporate
interests and we see that you know
there's just huge amounts of regulatory
capture where you have the executives
and the CEOs and the management teams of
large corporations going and on sitting
on the regulatory bodies that are
supposed to protect consumers from in
their best interests from you know
potentially nefarious interests on the
corporate side and so you see people
moving back and forth between the two
quite readily and this is why then you
get
you know potentially subsidies to
industries where otherwise the market
wouldn't be calling for them and you you
get into a situation where the companies
can then write the rules in their favor
they can actually influence the
regulator's we saw last year in big tech
all of the big the dominant firms there
spent records amount on lobbying and so
you see that there are you know
definitely very intentional spends and
activities that are trying to influence
regulators trying to influence you know
government decision making in their
favor there seems to be either I guess
we could call it a vicious cycle we
could call it a feedback loop where the
political system we have with the
influence peddling and kind of revolving
doors you're talking about of lobbyists
and elected officials and regulatory
capture that further allows the Oleg
appellee status quo to be perpetuated
and then the oligopoly status quo which
creates more and more powerful
corporations allows them to sort of
wield more influence over the political
system is has that always been the case
or is this acutely bad right now
well as you say it's totally self
reinforcing and in that kind of circular
way and I think that of course this is
you know in a way this has always
existed but I think it is particularly
bad at this point in history because one
of the main tools that's fallen away
from from being enforced to kind of
counteract this centralized power is
antitrust and we've seen a complete
drop-off in antitrust enforcement from
the DOJ and the FTC when the when the
original antitrust laws were first
introduced around the time of the Gilded
Age back you know at the turn of the
century there we had the big Trust's of
the day we had the Vanderbilts the
Rockefellers controlling entire
industries there too you know of
railroads and oil and people said that
they wanted the government to really
challenge and establish the kind of a
separation and definitely established
too
rules and laws that would help to limit
concentrated power in this way and I
think that you know we had a period of
great enforcement up through kind of the
the middle of the 1900s from the 30s
until the 80s and then in the 1980s
under President Reagan we had a
relaxation of merger guidelines as one
of the major contributing factors so
companies were allowed to merge really
without you know too much scrutiny and
all they had to do was say that they
would lower prices for consumers and as
long as they could sort of you know
claim that they would lower prices than
they were allowed to merge and so we've
seen you know decade after decade of
just merger wave after a merger wave
each one bigger than the last we saw you
know one of the largest merger years in
history under President Obama and then
to 2018 was another big one and so
what's that what that has done is then
it really has kind of precipitated this
consolidation within industries at the
same time the antitrust enforcement has
totally languished and so so really over
the last you know 30 to 40 years it has
become incredibly problematic and then
as you as you said at the beginning of
your question that has also helped to
precipitate this feedback loop between
kind of government and business interest
starting to more become more and more in
meshed is part of the problem that there
is not a huge difference in practice
between Democrats and Republicans on
this issue if we take a sort of zoomed
out view and I know that we have some
data points like Elizabeth Warren is now
talking about breaking up Amazon in
facebook although I think practically
speaking she doesn't do that or at least
not as presidential policy it would
depend on a big sort of justice system
initiative is it accurate to say that
even though the rhetoric is somewhat
different from Democrats and Republicans
that this is one of those issues that's
kind of within the general indifference
to the status quo that no one really
wants to get too deep with well I think
the historical legacy is certainly that
Democrats and Republicans have both been
equally complicit and allowing the
to happen you know as I mentioned the
mergers under Obama also there were more
visits to the White House ever than ever
in history by one company under Obama
and that was Google so but you can see
that you know yes essentially over the
last 40 years it doesn't really matter
who was in office neither neither party
took this as a priority I think now
we're in a situation where I am very
happy to see that this is entering kind
of the national conversation and you
know Elizabeth Warren has been
discussing these issues for the last few
years the break-up big tech I think was
a big splash and I'm very glad to see
that she's elevated the conversation in
this way you know I but I am hopeful
actually that this is strangely one of
the places that we could actually find
convergence as a country and that this
is a bipartisan issue because it affects
all Americans you know if you're a
worker you're essentially getting
screwed from this because you know
companies have the ability to well
they're just you you've had a real loss
of bargaining power and at the same time
that companies have you know increased
their their power relative to workers if
you're a consumer you're paying higher
prices for goods because when oligopoly
has become entrenched you they become
price makers and so you end up paying
you know higher prices for worse and
worse service because they're not
incentivized to serve you the airlines
are the best example of that and if
you're a supplier it's also equally
difficult because you're getting
squeezed out and so you know I think
these these questions aren't sort of
esoteric questions happening you know at
the at the level that you described in
turn in terms of you know regulatory and
legislative questions they really are
fundamental to kind of the fabric of our
democracy and the fabric of that the
type of economy that needs to work for
all Americans and so I think that's why
this is such an important conversation
and I'm really glad to see that that
some of the Democratic candidates are
taking it on I think we'll continue to
see Republican voices come to the
conversation as well and we've seen Josh
Haley of Missouri who is also a strong
Tec who's a Republican and so you know
there's there are increasingly more
conservative voices that are sort of
banging the drum as well but I'd love to
see even more it seems that there's the
the sort of like caricature conversation
which is free-market capitalism versus
quote socialism and then if we want to
actually have like an adult conversation
what we're really talking about is a
generally capitalist system that we
modify in different ways either we have
the sort of status quo we've had for
several decades which is we call it
capitalist but in reality we have
subsidies we have oligopolies we have
lack of enforcement when it comes to
antitrust or the social democracy model
that we're seeing in countries like
Sweden and Denmark and Norway where we
have a generally capitalist system but
we say we're going to prioritize social
welfare programs and pay for health
insurance and public college out of
taxation that seems to be the real
conversation but it's not really the one
that anybody's having yes I think I
don't agree more with you and I think
it's so silly in a way to say that we
want you know fully unfettered free
markets and the analogy I use is is that
you know if you showed up to a soccer
game and there were no pre-established
rules of engagement no rules to how you
score how many people are on a team you
know any there were no sort of structure
under which that game proceeds that
would be just be a horrible game to
watch nobody would want to watch it and
it would be subject to all kinds of you
know interference with things that
weren't helpful and I just think you
know the same is true with markets we
any marketplace is any type of exchange
is going to be subject to certain
expectations and certain rules and
structures that we've put in place to
help you know benefit the the and and to
help you know produce a conduit for that
exchange to take place so the the
discussion really isn't about kind of
free markets unfettered versus you know
big government socialism I think you're
exactly right that we need to have more
nuanced conversations about what kind
of capitalism what kind of you know what
kind of economy do we want to actually
be instituting and I'm actually Canadian
by birth and so you know we tend to skew
more sort of European as well in terms
of social democracy and I think that you
really see that you know these are
fundamental questions about when I think
about it you know I kind of think of
Maslow's hierarchy of needs and I think
what is an economy for an economy is for
much more than simply you know making
money what it is is that first you have
to have your basic needs met you know
then you move on to kind of the the
economy of belonging and creating
relationships and you know having
creating loving relationships finding a
partner yeah and then and then you get
to the self-actualization piece and
economies should be under girding the
human pursuit of of these these you know
beautiful journeys that we're all on and
I think you know that tends to get lost
in these conversations that are very
sort of there's a very divided in terms
of you know socialist virtues capitalist
and and as you said as well you know the
capitalism that we have in the United
States is incredibly different than the
capitalism in German Germany or Norway
and so I think there is so much more
room to have more nuanced conversations
along these lines about how we want to
be structuring you know all the various
pieces of this moving forward the book
is called the myth of capitalism
monopolies and the death of competition
we've been speaking with the books
co-author
Denis Hearn Denis thank you so much for
talking to us about this today thank you
very much